hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of The Walking Dead Season
eight episode 8 the mid-season finale
how it's gotta be and holy crap this
show just did the unthinkable diverging
from the comics in a major major way by
killing off a character we never thought
could die Neil beardy McGill top you
know known for his iconic catchphrase
damn straight which is also exactly the
direction of simon's bullet that went
through his head though it was a little
hard to see the lighting in the framing
was really weird here for a second I had
no idea who died I know guys I've been
stalling talking about the real shocker
here mostly to give people who don't
know what I'm talking about a chance to
avoid getting spoiled so get out of here
go watch the episode last chance if you
haven't seen this episode yet okay here
we go
Coral Grimes the season 1 Boy Wonder
whose plot armor has been as thick as
his luscious locks has been bitten and
according to actor Chandler Riggs this
bite is fatal guys no he's not immune to
walkers and no this wasn't a bite from
person I don't think there were any
terminus cannibals looking for a
midnight snack or ribs episode 9 in
February 2018 will be rig's final
episode guy apparently just bought a
house in Georgia near where the show
shoots
- this should scare the rest of you cast
members on The Walking Dead no one is
safe to invest in real estate now I'm
gonna dig into what happened here what
it means for the show and how it changes
what we've already seen and lots of
other admissible connections to past
episodes and other influences on this
game changing midseason finale let's
start with the big question brought to
us on Twitter by just another idiot hey
don't sell yourself short let's see aka
at a great white snark guy there we go
much better when did Carl get bit it
seems like he knew he was bit when he
was talking to negan and how will it
affect Rick's overall stability ok good
question first and foremost the question
of when in how Carl got hit and we
didn't see it happen in this episode and
that's because it actually happened two
episodes ago episode 6 when he helps to
deke clear all those walkers that were
feasting on that elk now I actually went
back to rewatch this scene and the show
did a really good job at hiding this
detail if you look closely Carl is
braced against the elk wrestling with
one wall
then he shoves that Walker off of him to
the side and another Walker grabs him
meanwhile in a very missable shot that
first Walker rolls back over and goes
for Carl's ribs but the camera cuts back
to Sadiq before we see that happen when
the camera cuts back to Carl he shoots
both Walker's and we all assumed that he
was just shaken up the way characters
always are on the show after they have
close run-ins with Walker's and barely
escaped but reexamining Chandler Riggs
his reaction here it's totally that of a
guy who just got bitten
there's a look of oh [ __ ] and a subtle
look down at his side where he's turned
away from Siddiq but then he turns back
to Siddiq with a new look of urgency and
resolve on his face as he says I'm
responsible for you now and sometimes we
have to find our own way to show our
parents the way so I love that the show
used this opportunity to remind us that
these routines couples can actually be
deadly
even for seemingly unkillable characters
I also like the subtle wink of this
happening to Karl next to the body of an
elk which is part of the antler deer
family well you know like the deer he
nearly died next to back in season two
this death sentence explains all of
Carl's behavior this episode it's why we
see him writing a goodbye note to his
father
it's why he offers to sacrifice himself
to Meighan because he knows he's gonna
die anyway
this also answers some questions we had
in the season premiere that old man Rick
future vision which included karl was
indeed hypothetical Riggs confirmed that
it was inspired by the time jump in the
comics but not literally that time jump
meanwhile we were probably right about
those other shots of teary eyed Rick he
most likely is burying someone here his
son Carl this season's opening montage
was showing us split futures for Rick
the fantasy one he planned with Carl and
the grim reality he has to live without
him also we should acknowledge how huge
Carl's departure is for the Walking Dead
killing Carl is more shocking and
killing Glenn which was adapted almost
word-for-word shot-for-shot from the
comics we knew that was coming but in
the comics Carl lives on to become a
major badass and power player he's the
catalyst for major events that are gonna
happen in the future now the show is
blazing a new course to adapt
these events without him but to be
honest I love the balls eNOS of this I
think the walking dead has been better
when they set a different course than
exactly what's in Robert Kirkman's
source material for example letting
Carol and Daryl be such decisive players
on the show it will also be interesting
to see what this death means for Rick
and for negan now I'll talk about that
with a deeper meaning later on but for
now let's talk about the way this
episode as a whole served as a sort of
tribute for Carl's character like that
elk deer connection I pointed out there
are a ton of little connections to past
memories of Carl that I want to go over
in our segment callbacks okay first you
probably notice the montage of character
close-ups that book ended this episode
most of these character faces were
completely pointless and red herrings as
is often the case on the show the show
actually use a similar montage in the
season 7 premiere to indicate that a
major character or in that case
characters were going to die this
montage became a sort of guess who death
mystery and has a similar effect here we
also see the second half of Rick and
Carl's conversation from the season
premiere where Carl chastise Rick for
only hoping that Sadiq would be okay
rather than showing true mercy and
bringing him into the community
remembered that scene with Carl
scavenging for gas was a shot-for-shot
recreation of Rick in the pilot episode
seeing Carl with the gas can beside his
dad here reminds us of that time when
Rick was alone when he assumed Carl was
probably dead and it suggests those dark
times are coming back there were some
callbacks with Karlin Enid - Carl
rediscovers that goodbye note ian had
left him at the beginning of season 6
just survives somehow this is where we
learned the meaning of Enid's jss mantra
and it also jokes to Aaron that she's a
better driver than Carl that's a
callback to season 7 when Carl followed
Enid and ran over a walker to save her
totaling a car in the process there are
more parallels between this shocking
death episode in the season 6 finale
shocker death episode Maggie runs into a
similar down trees Savior roadblock that
blocked her and the others in that
episode and the image of Jerry as he
rolls out of the back of the Savior's
truck lit by the headlights of a car is
definitely meant to evoke for Maggie
that image of Glenn but I don't really
know how well Maggie really knows Jerry
right like Simon's probably like Oh
check it out Widow we got your best
friend
Maggie's like um you mean that jokey
dude with the axe from the kingdom yeah
yeah sure I guess we're friends whatever
negan also joins in on a Carl
memorializing he shouts over the walls
of Alexandria's suggesting that people
apologize to him in creative ways riot
poems sharing a song I loved that [ __ ]
sing me a song was the title of episode
7 last season it was a line from negan
that episode when she when he made Carl
sing to him Carl remember saying you are
my sunshine a song that his mother sang
to him when he was a kid
later negan again references how Carl
was actually with his mother when she
died so we're seeing all of Carl's major
life moments on the show being mentioned
again this episode
negan also mentions going to rick's
house and making some spaghetti which is
a call back when negan and carl made
spaghetti at rick's place in episode 8
of last season negan and carl had an
interesting relationship last season
it's almost like negan respected carl as
a man with a backbone who takes action
kind of like negan could see carl
becoming a successor to Rick that he
could actually work with I could see a
mutual mourning of Carl being something
that could unite Rick and negan not
anytime soon of course gonna take Rick
some time to fully grieve and process
the message that Carl was trying to get
through to him a few other interesting
callbacks that I noticed
címon points to the sound of an opera
singer in the distance crediting Eugene
as the way they escaped from the walkers
at the sanctuary
it's still not totally clear how exactly
the Savior's got out but it sounds like
Eugene rigged up a similar fat lady type
redirect device like the glider and
speaker that he tested out last episode
now Dwight shot that one down but
there's no reason to believe that Eugene
couldn't build a new type of device also
when Dwight joins Daryl and the others
notice how daryl snatches his vest back
from him this is a callback to Dwight
stealing Daryl's vest at the end of
season six he's been wearing it ever
since good on Daryl for getting that
back and when Ezekiel closes and locks
the kingdom gates to allow Carol and
Elias to escape no so he leaves her with
this little smile now for me this is a
literal example of Ezekiel's idealistic
worldview that he outlined in his speech
at the beginning of episode 4 this
season and yet I smile
this smile here suggests that after his
crushing defeat Ezekiel has returned to
that optimistic strength
speaking of Ezekiel I like how he uses
this
Chane as a sort of prop this episode now
remember this chain used to be Ezekiel's
chain for Shiva is Tiger
but ever since Shiva died he's been
moping by the throne with this chain
it's almost like now this chain has been
restraining him imprisoning him in his
own shame but by the end of this episode
this chain becomes a tool of Ezekiel's
self liberation he uses the same chain
to lock the doors of the kingdom and
protect his people by finding a news for
the object that was holding him down
Ezekiel finds a new use for himself I
like that another detail I found
interesting was the roanoke way
distillery that Enid and Aaron stopped
by to bring a welcoming gift for
Oceanside that obviously goes unused
after Netanya gets accidentally shot now
Roanoke is a city Virginia though
geographically it's actually pretty far
from Alexandria I don't think it's the
actual city of Roanoke historically
Roanoke originally referred to the
English colony on Roanoke Island North
Carolina if you know your history
Roanoke is called the Lost Colony it was
a loosely established in 1585 on that
Island but when an expedition team
returned to check in on it the colony
had mysteriously vanished no trace at
all of the 90 men 17 women or 11
children nor any sign of a struggle or a
battle all the houses and fortifications
had been dismantled meaning the
departure wasn't really rushed all they
found was the word Croatoan carved into
a nearby post now Croatoan was the name
of a local native tribe and the name of
a nearby Croatoan Island so it was
implied that the colonists moved on to
that Island but it still remained a
mystery over the centuries
anyway this Roanoke mystery could be
connected to Karl and the others having
to vacate their colony Alexandria though
of course the all the houses getting
bombed and blown up absolutely makes
this more of a battle than heroic was
now before I move on to the deeper
meaning I wanted to revisit this idea of
Karl somehow being immune to the Walker
virus can he survive this now it's a
pretty out-there theory but let's talk
about it by activating theory time okay
so in many real-world epidemics it's
said that one percent of the population
is naturally immune to viral infections
and many believe that in this show Rick
and Carl possess that genetic
irregularity both of them has sustained
major injuries before Rick spin shots
Carl got shot in the eye and had his
brains blown out kind of and they have
both miraculously survived these mortal
wounds without dying or succumbing to
the zombie virus that overtakes most
people on the show when they die now
someone suggested this could point to
Carl being the source of a cure in the
future of the show personally I don't
think it's the case Robert Kirkman has
repeatedly said that he doesn't want the
Walking Dead to follow the formula of
other zombie stories many of which end
with some vaccine being discovered
instead Kirkman wants The Walking Dead
to keep going and assuming these zombie
apocalypse is irreversible to explore
what new society could emerge in that
hypothetical world so to make Carl
immune would be completely contrary to
what the Walking Dead is all about and
given how definitive the cast and crew
has been about Carl's death this would
be an even more annoying pointless
switcheroo on viewers even worse than
Glenn crawling out from under that
dumpster in season 6 there are no
dumpsters for coral alright let's move
on to the deeper meaning this episode
these mid season finale is called how
it's gotta be a quote from Carl early in
the episode when he tries to explain to
his father then need to be merciful to
the Savior's sure it's a little weird to
think about how Carl's death was caused
by him needlessly clearing some Walker's
with this relative stranger Siddiq based
on the Explorers belief that putting
down Walker's releases their souls but I
do think that it shows how stubborn Carl
was being on this point how important it
was for him to show his father the
importance of mercy Carl needed to form
a connection with a stranger who like
him is guided by his late mother's
values and by telling sadik's sometimes
we have to find our own way to show our
parents the way Carl indicated to us
that his top priority is tempering his
father's fierce righteousness with a
sense of understanding and empathy that
a real leader requires so I'm assuming
this will be a message that Carl makes a
bit more explicitly in his final episode
of February because judging from Rick's
reaction here I think he's more in a
state of good old-fashioned Rick Grimes
bewilderment it looks a bit infected a
bit infected cool sorry whatever I guess
I should be taking this moment a bit
more seriously but so long as Ric has
hope for the future in the survival of
its daughter Judith losing Karl despite
the shock it delivers to us fans of the
comics and viewers who have had
different ideas of the future of the
show this is a powerful enough force to
make a major change in bricks
perspective unfortunately a brutal
reminder of the stakes is how it's got
to be see what I did there Tyrell the
absolute core yeah I'm sorry I'm gonna
check in on the kill count right now
this episode showed a lot of characters
accessing their inner killers
Enid killed Netanya promotion side Simon
killed Neal you know beer d'emic Hilltop
Maggie killed Dean the Savior Michonne
brutally slaughtered another Savior and
more saviors were killed in that
shootout but by my count
Dwight tops a list as a deadliest
shooting at least four of his own people
now he was right to tell Terrell and the
others that he cannot go back this is
officially him crossing enemy lines and
joining the other side but I'm curious
somewhat you guys to answer a question
which character death in The Walking
Dead do you think has had the biggest
impact on the show now obviously the
deaths of people like Glenn and Abraham
Beth Hershel Laurie and Shane were game
changers but damn I think the death of
Carl could top them all in terms of how
Rick's overall trajectory has been
altered comment down below to let me
know your thoughts on this and and on
this mid-season finale in general what
you think tweet me directly at EI vas
and follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for updates on our videos
now this video was brought to you by our
good friends at loot crate loot crate is
a monthly subscription box service for
epic geek and gamer items and pop
culture gear for less than $20 a month
you get six to eight items that include
licensed gear apparel collectibles
unique one-of-a-kind items and more it's
great there's always stuff in there that
I would just never think to buy for
myself but I end up loving all of it
loot crate has supported youtubers since
the company shipped its first crate so
by supporting loot crate you're really
supporting our channel sign up at loot
crate comm slash rockstars and enter the
code rockstars to save 10% on any new
subscription or click on the link in the
description now I'm gonna impact last
month's crate here it has the theme of
unite I just want to give you an idea of
what to expect in these things
[Music]
the December lootcrate theme is explore
and it contains cool items from Destiny
to Star Wars guardians of the galaxy and
a mystery property you have until the
19th at 9 p.m. Pacific to subscribe and
receive that month's great and when the
cutoff happens that's it it's over
so get on this start collecting great
gear you will thank me later
like this video and subscribe to new
rockstars for deep obsessive analysis of
The Walking Dead and make sure to check
out my breakdowns of all the episodes
this season for all the other stuff you
might have missed I really appreciate
you guys sticking through it with me I
think we've had a great time made some
interesting insights I made a couple
mistakes you guys been great about that
in the comments and if you really want
to help this channel you can help
contribute in any small amount to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our current
donors especially Laurie Denning thanks
for watching guys see you next year
bye